a hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
you joke oh yeah because he's Asian huh
hey you know what you should do why had
a little color in your show bro look at
my shows I got two black guys open this
weekend for me bro
first of all you got the I mean your hey
his son is a sand black he's not with me
this weekend I tell Lacey and Derrick
posted the closest thing I got to like
you're gonna wait our Derrick's whiter
than half the dudes I know
first of all B you're going way dark
with Chappelle he's so dark but he's
whiter than me and you inside yeah oh
yeah he's like one of those like
chocolate rabbits you get it Easter with
that vanilla Center yeah he's like a cat
oh yeah he's a Cadbury brother he's a
cat baby brother filled with white yeah
you got that white girl big green day
yeah oh dude I patted him on the back
the other day started singing all the
small this guy is very this guy's
one-of-a-kind and then we played I play
basketball with them even wider really
the worst white I've ever seen play
hoops oh really
yeah I select him number one standard
because he's the darkest guy not that
really huh worst I've ever seen oh wow
does he run when he should is he liked
shoot it's just a nightmare it was just
so sad when you see that you know it's a
real bummer it is a really what happened
where did you go wrong maybe he grew up
right by a library or something how does
it even have babies baby spit sitter was
Spencer's like what are we doing yeah
but imagine being a guy you know a
strong brother and not being able to
hoop going to the hoop court jumping
rope or something people like what no he
was doing backflips and trying to be a
cheerleader like all right dude it's
like being black him a small dick the
worst dude they're worse the worst about
thinking about that you're yo you're not
no well there's some stereotypes for a
reason it's still morning bro I'm not
thinking about black you know anybody's
dick before and this is starting to feel
racist to me dude
well did let's go for a full circle here
I was just saying you should
be put a little pepper into your show oh
yeah
I came to shows it looks like goddamn
Trump round first of all if it is a
trump rally he won so he's basically the
Toronto Raptors okay be um what was the
question again just how you need a
pepper up your shows man I come and it's
like a goddamn KKK I got re man us out
there this smokey little Jew dude so
he's always taking pictures I'm sure
he's gonna sue me in a couple years for
something he's probably taking money
from you now I hope he is you know what
I'm saying Opie is - yeah so but yeah I
thought about getting somebody dude yeah
I mean you're getting dark I have you
been tanning have you just been out in
the Sun no you're dead so you're darker
than me right now I think you wanna saw
the same shade yeah that's kind of uh
yeah it's pretty true actually well
[Laughter]
there's the only brother in here but no
we got a lot of we got a beautiful
culture corner today Derick got that
haircut huh looking saucy right up off
my hair dog you know what made you
decide to do that cuz that's a big
decision you had kind of the yeah you
had like a but kind of a black guy that
plays basketball in the seventies style
yeah there you know I was gonna let you
take that one before yeah yeah it might
own that yeah you had that baby
Frederick Douglass rock I mean it was
just time I saw one of the comments said
I look like Krusty the Klown if you grew
up in Compton
you know it's time Derrick you uh he's
gonna go on the other night in Dave
Chappelle confront about me tell this
story yo so there's more people in the
belly room I'm about to go up my friend
is bringing up another door guy and he's
going he has no idea Dave's in the room
right I'm thinking like oh this is my
moment Dame's watching and he goes I
hate me the next guy coming up he's my
best friend used to sleep on my couch
you know he smokes a lot of weed here
he's just joking around and then Dave
goes alright I'm going up and I'm like
and so I walked because back and then
that goes alright guys Dave Chappelle
Dave walks up and he goes I don't know
who that they're gonna go
but his credits were terrible I left and
then like ten minutes later they come
and grab me all these days looking for
you looking for you I run back up he
starts going back and forth of me he's
like you know what up man I'm sorry I
had to bump you but you know I had to do
it I was like it's all good bruh he goes
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you black I don't let you
go up hey we just played it was great
that's cool dude funny yeah at least
next time you see me you could say so
you know talk to him or whatever that's
great yeah it was also Spectre part of
it also sucks really art is [ __ ] it's
your own people bumping you know jib
point well there's also a lot of
problems in the black community where
they you know they don't share
opportunities as one another unless you
know preach yeah that's just a rap group
but yeah I mean they'll throw as many
people let you want to be a bodyguard
dude you know they'll let you in all
that all day sometimes I feel like a
black guys born in like a circus has
security on the back yeah they can can
we just start this episode four are you
any more races
but I love how asana day is in the worst
disguise ever the worst I've ever seen
hey Isis do better Halloween costume for
Isis spy it looks like that the same
time look nice man you definitely look
like kind of guy look like a syrup ER
you look like that kind of mysterious
syrup ER in Vermont you know like oh
who's that guy over there tapping into
that tree no he looks like uber driver
in Portland that when you bring it up it
says likes to talk or if he looks like a
dude if you walked into blockbuster he's
gonna tell you the history of the movies
you want to see you said knows his [ __ ]
about movies that'd be kind of cool if
they had that feature in a blog less
like a film historian you walk in and
you're like oh let's get this guy you
know they got to show us around a little
bit he takes you on a tour of all right
of all the movies
yeah baby - yeah like Danny McBride play
that guy how about a sons dad the
straight-up rocket scientist never
people have taught you this actually
yeah I just tech some Brody think of
this well the time does your dad think
we went to the moon or not did he say
anything oh yeah he definitely we
definitely went to the moon according to
him yeah yeah but how does he know I
trust him I trust him he's your dad
family trust he's your dad something I'm
not very familiar with actually Derek's
dad told him Batman lived in Nashville
for the longest because they have that
building with the two ears I told him it
was Bruce Wayne's building thought that
until we went the city skyline he goes
dude that's Batman on it what the [ __ ]
you talking heart broken dude he had a
terrible show that you really it kind of
stuck was heartbroken but you look very
tan bro do I
you look very tan who's been sleeping
indoors you went to Vic you went to
Vegas I did go to Vegas homes Vegas I
was awesome are you a Vegas fan do some
guy in the middle and I was peeing off
of a bridge but it was indoors I don't
think he realized that he was like it
was like one of those like is that like
the Venetian where they have like the
Italian gondola yeah it's out yes yeah
this guy's [ __ ] up dude you gotta go
outdoors I told him yeah that's the
problem you never ever see the outside
in Vegas they do it on purpose
well they almost build a lot of outdoors
indoors cuz hey you know you walk
through this part it's like a little
forest yeah man if you're dumb you could
be in there hunting you know weird
relationship with Vegas man it's not I
mean people love it I just I don't know
it's not really me not for me dude all
right we'll see dude yeah you do look
very tan though I do
yeah you look tan quit looking at my
skin and row okay it's kind of just
right in your eyes and that's it that's
it look at the rest of another man yeah
no you crazy guy all right dude just
saying like super tan dude really yeah
it's not a bad thing I suck maybe you
got some going on mm-hmm
I don't know what it is maybe some type
of deficiency or something you think
that's a good thing
let's kick this off dude feel actually
real quick somebody got you tatted on
them dawg are you serious dead serious
and I mean tatted is that the Obamas
that
baking melting yep Oh that's Kevin Bacon
from hallow man impression there's a rat
as a sidekick
oh my god that's beautiful first of all
the tattoo is good the guy did a great
job with the tattoo on that he got that
knows for sure bro can you quit talking
about my nose I can't talk about you
know you can I'd say me that good son or
sometime okay oh you have a nice I saw
about your skin earlier dude like that
man yeah you said it was tan it was nice
I'm sorry I didn't call you white my bad
well what I'm saying is I think I think
they did a really accurate job one yeah
I think it's great it's really really
good work I wish I looked better than
that and regularly that's the sad thing
about a tattoo it's like man damn that's
how I look portraits are tough
corsets are tough one I done and it's
game over yeah game over
your minds don't match I think there's
definitely somebody out there as one of
my eyes
I love the rat though right there huh
that rat is saucy yeah no that's a dope
tattoo right a saucy man oh wait and I
met the guy who did this for in
Disneyland actually I met the guy that
did does this tattoo I think really yeah
I can't believe I didn't see yeah
does he do tattoos there at Disneyland
when was this do you know it was
yesterday
Oh what if it's still on my Instagram I
could share it does he do tattoos in the
haunted house what's going on here
is that where you met him do we know did
it yeah he the guy that he also is the
driver on the Jungle Cruise is he really
I don't know dude you're the one I met
him at Disneyland I'm Jamie but night
ideas up Jamie Lee Parker Jamie Lee
Parker dude first of all sounds like
somebody that's up shooter president Oh
inkmaster c-section or has a set of
double D's and make pornos Jamie what is
it Jamie leave Jamie Lee Parker they
were on ink master season 11
I bet Kevin Bacon's thrilled about it
that's it's really good work man the
coloring the shadings ridiculous is that
a calf
yeah like that there's a long tit I
thought I thought someone's neck I
thought your boy long neck oh dang I'll
be gravity I thought long I gotta be so
wild if he got that just you on the side
of his neck the worst tattoo this is
like lick here's this point I'd like
someone his chest the air is kind of
awful hey but of course yeah of course
that's true yeah that's what he would
have yeah that's dope what else is you
can put your whole family tree on Will
Sasso SCAF oh you put your mom brother
animals everything biggest cap I've ever
seen really oh my god that's big um cabs
huh
he's just a big dude yeah the biggest
friend we have dude how could you wear
that much yellow and just be okay when
you leave the house what do you mean
what do you mean dude what's wrong with
Mikey was about that much yellow you
have a yellow watch you have a yellow
hat well this is gold but sorry if I get
old whatever it's so yellow yellow yeah
dude you yellow you're in sweats head to
toe never now sorry is it sweat Friday
okay did everyone get the memo and the
email address like [ __ ] I'm sorry
are you flying spirit dude you look like
your picture outfit out from that place
where you trade in tickets at Dave &
Buster's
you look like a lifeguard of a junkyard
look like that you look like Patrick
Swayze you got kind of tanning bed you
look like Patrick Swayze twinks dude you
look like Kevin Bacon for you grew up in
Sri noble that's what that tattoo looks
like where'd you get the head in a Lion
King gift shop that people are ruining
they go in dangerous people are
basically in the woods chanting you're
the last one Wow bad knock knock who's
there an advertisement oh yeah man
nobody knows about looking good like me
boy mm-hmm okay that guy oh sorry I just
walked past a mirror dude you do look
good you do look in summertime serum and
most people have hats on but not you
dude I'm wearing a hat today because I'm
like gives my hair getting thinner how
do I look like Theo and then some your
friends told me there's a reason why
you're here so thick dude dude you look
like a little lemon nugget brush look
like a bald nugget look the truth is
that summer time is right now
fall is coming up winter and then it'll
be spring and then it'll be summer again
and obviously ball yeah and your hair
does and the truth is also you just got
to keep yourself looking tight go to
four hams calm a one-stop-shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
the bros yeah Kim's connection with real
doctors medical great solutions to treat
that hair loss bro yeah it's okay to be
bald and it's okay or it's okay to be a
wreck tyldus funked but you can't be
both okay now don't be probably Brian
and listen there's no way to room no
awkward in person doctor visits there's
none that save by going to for hims calm
it's easy answer a few questions a
doctor looks at it prescribed you what
you need come straight to your door
that's how easy it is and you guys get a
trauma of
for just $5 today right now while
supplies last tell him how to do it deal
oh I'll tell you how to do it because
you don't even know this would cost
hundreds of dollars Brendon dang dude
you went to the doctor or pharmacy so
just go to for hems dot-com /k ATS
that's fo r h i M s I'm spelling
something Brendon ok.com /k a TS for
hems dot-com / cats get your hair up get
your wiener up and get right stay right
see website for full details and safety
information time to buy field more pants
yo deal transformation an important part
of our lives especially guys like you
and me especially guys like you man I
know you I noticed that you are
definitely transforming into something
different and so are you look at your
haircut
I dig it I don't care what they say yeah
you'll be refined a year yeah yeah we're
always evolving and growing which makes
life interesting our sponsors of this
segment Wix invites you to tell the
story of your career transformation
visually by design your new homepage on
wit oh yeah Wix guys everything you need
if you think about a different template
or a different you know a pattern all of
that stuff it's a lot it's so much
easier than you thank you you don't have
to hire some big architect you don't
have to draw up plans and do plumbing
and all of that Wix has it all it offers
hundreds of templates unlimited pages
and top-grade hosting for free they have
this cool competition too man and I'm
encouraging you and so steel Kingston
Lister's to build their most imaginative
creative homepage and a homepage that
highlights why your career journey is
unique just like you guys Wix is the
free platform that empowers you to build
the highly custom ole robust websites oh
wow and he said it bust it yeah the
competition just go to wix.com /k ats to
start your own Wix website for free and
then email your submissions to Wix loves
cats wi x LOV es k 80s at gmail.com this
home page is the bomb check it out right
at the top we see the name of Edgar's
business edy creatives with some
images from his portfolio this
definitely works because the visuals
speak for themselves and get you in the
mood to see more oh and look notice how
everything we need to see is above the
fold for easy access I mean you got the
Instagram button on the upper left with
relevant links across the top edgers
homepage is exactly what this
competition is all about all right a
home page needs to invite people in to
learn more and vivid imagery is the best
way to do that good work man
yep we'll review the best emissions from
you guys and we will let you know who
wins and we'll announce the grand prize
winner of the wicks business VIP
premiere plan free for one year a value
420 bucks starting next week we're gonna
review some of the websites that you
guys submit and and in five weeks we
will pick a winner and what are they
gonna win be four hundred and twenty
bucks man the premier plan once again go
to wix.com slash ghosts slash cats
submit your best homepage to Wix loves
cats
at gmail.com good luck yep good luck
support the podcast let's do this man
yeah yeah let's get in let's get into
this let's start a little clown my hound
boys first this is Zeus we got Zeus and
what Zeus oh wow a powerful looking dog
is a big feller
and hey is this racist sometimes I see
dogs I think like what ethnicity would
own that dog we know what would all this
talk well you see anything it could be I
don't know do I do
that's not that that's that's that's a
boxer right well that could be a British
dog a boxer is a British dog dude owner
you see a British boxer the you think of
the wrestler the WWE wrestler boxer
British the Bulldog British the Bulldog
beefcake yeah talk about a beefcake
oh yeah there's also a boys cheeked up
too if you remember a boy's cheek yeah
first kind of England with not a flat
ass yeah you did have a nice ass what
kind of dogs you guys have out there you
saw on oh there you guys oh my whole
family is like afraid of dogs I'm not
trying to be racing do you guys like
cats right we have no pets in our family
what
well what about the general well that's
obviously if someone doesn't have pets
dude is because they're not planning on
being alive very much
hey because they're planning on
sacrificing themselves yeah we just have
a lot of meeting rooms conference tables
that's kind of suck man if you grew up
in a house where you know like you're
everybody's a terrorist you're just like
oh yeah we're all just gonna die in a
couple years be tough to get excited to
run errands on Saturdays yeah
what have to clean the pool dad
we're all gonna be dead
[Laughter]
this bar needs more gasoline in the core
gets a leaner gasoline aha well we need
more Mexican [ __ ] bombers dude
there's no Mexican terrorists they got
their cartels but whatever you know yeah
but I would love to see that there would
be a good movie huh
about a Mexican on it's a special type
of dude to blow yourself up and what
does it call to me that bosoms of them
it's not a philanthropist is the
opposite of a philanthropist do weed
that that wild Mexican terrorists honor
you know Caballero on a horseback that
little jalapeno hit her yeah it's
[ __ ] running around that double
decker hitter be yeah it'd be beautiful
all right yes this dog is really a whole
podcast turning a bunch of racism was
darken up your audience a little bit you
won't understand jack
like your name's [ __ ] Dukes from do
capacitated two guys just sharing back
fence with David dude we see or the gym
actually that's true story but yeah dude
I'll tell you this man what choose
carefully what you say now oh yeah look
I'll tell you what means that you're
really good job
a matter of fact when things start a
podcast again called make America great
he just he taught he taught me some
weightlifting exercises and stuff like
that skinny stuff but he was jacked back
in the day really he's to date the
finest girl that worked at this seafood
restaurant I worked at and she black
Stephanie I think her name was her
Jessica which is basically the same name
[ __ ] can we shut one of those names
down okay is Stephanie dude it's like
Mary Sarah yeah
same get rid of them but yeah he uh and
we would go to the gym sometimes man
because we shared the back fence I never
saw him do anything you know egregious
do with you then recycled so it's like
you know he always had his recycling bin
out there I just what cut was hard to
believe that he was also that you know a
guy who was just you know really super
Pro white you know really you didn't
none of that came off to you I don't
know man I mean I didn't see that side
of him in signs no I think it was just
like a period in his life where he's
like oh yeah I'm gonna this is what I
think I'm gonna get into and then he was
like I know it's not really the coolest
thing and he just kind of got back into
the gym do you think I think so cuz I
think he was too comfortable driving the
n-bomb around everybody you know when
you put on LL Cool J and he freaked the
[ __ ] out and didn't go to the gym that
wasn't a red flag dude did he listen -
boys - man I remember so you gotta maybe
he's just doing homework it could be it
man but anyway yeah this dog seems first
of all this dog seems oldest [ __ ] ski
bro and this thing obviously has
breathing issues yes Ted hates sleeping
next to this [ __ ] loud Muppet well
they sent a video of them that's abuse
brother that's assault brother damn bro
yeah that dog went all out
he's like a white receiver in the NFL
I've gotta make the team roam or
whatever it take well I don't know
do that in between why he's kind of in
between like when he's kind of like a
Plaxico Burress pretty of the white
mentality has some saving abilities and
then [ __ ] shoots himself in the pool
right at the last minute Wow bro okay
wow that was intense
let me good if you guys can't see this
at home.this the hog runs about a
hundred yards right into a truck and not
a moving truck I want to tell you the
dog is a dog
they definitely did on purpose it's a
part car apparently drew brees through
this frisbee cuz about 150 yards now
this dog sells out
definitely a CT from it and you talked
he looks like a dumbass in the snow
beige so out of it in the pictures off
and wasn't wonderful nose was pointy at
the winning in this because his nose is
very flat at the end here's the nose
like medi-pack y'all know guy yeah he
real I mean this is insane how do you
can pull this off me this dog runs and
runs right into that [ __ ] truck jumps
right into the side of it hey I saw a
Doberman off i-10 one time over by the
UM
rest area and it jumped out of a back of
a pickup truck while the truck was 170
miles in the interstate and literally
just scattered in a different piece
useful oh we're driving oh yeah died
this thing jumped right out the back
yeah and did he died I'm sure he died I
mean I don't if he can be alive and
being like 15 different pieces but uh
could be Terminator 2 you know that's
true yeah could have been yeah so maybe
he's a lot but it looked like he was
dead but he okay it was a different time
man it's a different time back when I
don't think dogs were as excited about
their lives well people don't care about
him as much no now [ __ ] man okay
anything oh yeah you see that youtubers
slapping that dog around uh-uh
no man I don't watch I kind of said what
are y'all doing what are you doing huh
it's all over the I'm living fear you're
not living man living
no you weren't it's all over the
Internet mmm-hmm
what else we got I like that hand up
next we got Sparky
this is Sparky
who's Sparky mmm
he likes to masturbate to other male dog
oh so he's rubbing his wiener on the
floor huh yeah oh it's the louis c.k of
dogs apparently just jacking off next on
the sing how old is you think ballpark
you know mmm that's a chihuahua man they
are they're an interesting [ __ ] Bree
dude we had a chihuahua bus growing up
biggest dick you ever seen really oh so
bad for the guy
yeah it's exhaust I was born with like
an adult penis and uh and it's just hard
you don't realize the labor people go
through you know hold it stop carrying
that way bro it's like big titties I
don't think of oh how fun are those
gonna be I think of their back pain oh
well these I'm so tired I don't want to
lift up some big oh I don't want that
tattoo my flip those [ __ ] yourself
you drew them you know I'm lifting some
big two-hander you grew those [ __ ]
watermelon yeah you grew those bean bags
man there's some ladies have these bean
bag out of kids sitting on one of them
there's like a PlayStation remote like
tucked away in between dude it's a
control bro oh they're just to give it
to out of control man yeah - out of
control these big titties and loiterers
brah big [ __ ] milk jugs right what the
[ __ ] is his dog sinasohn and they got
this don't count awesome but to the docs
point he's jacking off to the side if in
the dog world the dog in from does have
some cakes that's a good point
the dogs cheeked up if he look at the
picture again that doggy has some cakes
out the back yeah that dog really got a
real butt on him you know sometimes
butts you know they just aren't on girls
you know I'm a heterosexual man but
sometimes I get the airport I saw this
dude Derek and a song can vouch for this
we saw this guy at the Burbank Airport
top 5 best asses I've ever seen I got
off the plane I went whoa whoa whoa I'm
gonna stop stop look at that guy's ass
everyone whoa
these khakis yeah and this [ __ ] blow
out ass man the out the bat it was
distracting gonna made a lot of money
someone else yes they do don't check my
luggage yeah
shake them cheek he was real cheeked up
on us being never seen anything like it
we're going sick one bar clear so I'm
sure it was just wow yeah it's amazing
hmm I'll probably see him tomorrow he'll
I don't know if I see anybody's ass I
know if I never seen a real good ass on
a man I don't think it's very rare it's
very rare we used to have this guy uh
and he was a librarian he had a pretty
nice ass I remember and they're always
in khakis yeah this guy wasn't cat yeah
actually yeah but that makes sense if
you got a nice ass you ain't puttin it
in no Kinkos or nothin you know treat it
right yeah yeah treat it right does
think I remember about khakis to one of
the reasons why that ass pops out the
back because if you're in khakis you're
kind of a dork or it's a uniform yeah
tuck the shirt in so that ass flops up
oh yeah you know I'm saying
yeah the polo tucked in you might have a
ridiculous ass but you always have baggy
clothes on we don't know you're right
just like Roseanne Texas bro you look
really a battle side piece and you guys
have this same stylist characters that
just shows up on drugs like everybody
else is like the red line the red
strawberry the the green line Anna and
you're the [ __ ] banana that [ __ ]
left home early you you look at one of
those people from breaking Amish that
leaves and [ __ ] comes back a week
later all ten just experienced
everything in one week I had a great
time
you got 60 tats what a bunch of bad
shirts a couple fake roly's and suddenly
you don't have to use a shovel anymore
time to pay the bills actually you got
yours got mine right here do you put
them in years
put him in years bro you're not putting
anything in my ears dude or any part of
my body
what I'm in myself put those red cones
in your ear dude yes in there now Rick
do you listen little Dave Matthews in
that I listen to actually no I have a
live feed from dave and buster's over
there outside of austech romano now that
makes sense
oh yeah people are doing all right oh
yeah somebody's on whack-a-mole huh
Oh perfect dude listen it's still 19 be
like feel everyone needs a great pair of
wireless earbuds but before you go
dropping hundreds of dollars like
everybody else you need to check out the
new wireless earbuds from Raycom Slim
Shady recon earbuds they started about
half the price of any other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and they
sound just as amazing yeah they sound
like you paid full price yeah the
company was actually co-founded by Ray J
and celebrities like Snoop Dogg cardi B
Melissa Etheridge Brandi
r.i.p and jr. Smith interesting rake on
Z 50 Wow earbuds have totally changed
the game for us man they're so comfy I
wear them on the plane and unlike some
of your other Wireless options rake on
earbuds are both stylish and discreet
there's no wires or stems hanging off we
don't need that do ya sometimes the
stems look like you know what's going on
with it what is this guy a plant buddy
braid is here yeah somebody just come
and pour water on you no it's not
and listen Rick on offers the wireless
earbuds for everyone a range of fun
colors at on beatable price go to buy
rake on.com slash cats get 15% off your
order
that's buy rake on.com slash cats for
15% off rake on wireless earbuds if
you've been eyeing a pair now's the time
to get you some one more time
buy rake on Bui RA Y Co in.com slash K
ATS get these rake on bad boys Phil year
with sound
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit bro one thing I'm into is
fashion and a lot of dudes on the
streets making a lot of mistakes they're
looking real fly head to toe but they're
forgetting one thing I know it they had
sakis dough and sock Ups
warm those feet up huh nothing I hate
seeing more on a man than a cold little
hoof yeah doc you a stylish Huff you
need to wrap them in some Stan's socks
yeah you got to have a stance dude some
time you see somebody and they don't
know what they're doing they're laying
down when they should be standing up
they got no stance baby yeah you right
and a lot of people like Oh stance and
there's a bunch of copycats out there
but there's one original there's a bunch
of pretenders but there's only one
stance millions of socks yeah million
incredible designs in comfort with
unmatched durability from everyday
casual styles to styles from your
favorite sports what about their collabs
bro you're talking Kid Cudi Pulp Fiction
blue tang stepbrothers Disney Marvel II
Eilish Vlad Carhartt and Allen Iverson
to name a few CAI
how about stranger things what's up bro
guess what Stan's also gives back to the
community socks for Heroes which sends
socks deployed military people around
the world what's up man what's up relax
here's what I'm saying Stan's has a
great offer for our listeners if you go
to Stan's comm /k ATS you'll get a free
pair of socks with your purchase so
think about this free socks st ance dot
c om / k 80s to get your free pair of
socks you know we're not just talking
any suction I can Stan's the best socks
on planet earth this is a limited offer
so take advantage of today go to Stan's
comm slash cats if they're not Stan's
they're just
that's right sometimes people use socks
to stuff their crotch to look a little
harder at the beach right use them as
mittens yeah so at least do it with
quality socks Stan's Stan's trying to
keep lights on what else we got up next
we got a little debate club boys first
this is Caleb from Phoenix oh wow
a local Phoenix doing the Lord deal hey
Brandon got debate club for years hit me
first the general lead Hill City to
Hazzard or the Train
Sam from Smokey and the Bandit what do
you guys think what would you rather
have I know Brandon you're a little bit
of a car guy here so you might be more
interested in this one for me I'm think
of the Trans Am gang but let me know
getting gang buzz-buzz goes first of all
funny we mentioned Dukes Hazzard and he
brought it up again that's called
serendipity cop psychology idiot second
of all this guy let me guess which one
feels gonna pick first of all the guys
dressed like is there a reason that guys
dressed like Saturn is he live from
Chernobyl what is he dressed like that
the Hatter was yet a party or something
Caleb Yuka right there my boy right
there oh I thought he was that like us
like you know I don't know yeah maybe
he's that special I thought he's at a
rave or something that generally is
badass and that thing can hop bro that's
the thing about the generally you do we
jump over is that all you like about it
do you like about it it's a beautiful
car say I know
yeah it's southern hitter yeah dude is
it nice did you and your boy do boys
never meanin along my only neighbor tall
with money
dude low listen man I'm gonna be honest
I've never seen the show because I'm not
racist so the thing is about the Trans
Am dude give me a jean jacket putting on
a little [ __ ] white snake give you a
jean jacket seventy then I do love denim
dude I love them I needed to hook you up
with some sort of fat oh I'm a TransAm
guy and I'll see the Dukes of Hazzard
racist first of all Dukes Hazzard one of
the top B it's beautiful car first of
all one of the only who who else has
ever done an orange car nobody dude well
I mean t-pain has a ton of them does he
kill but still I think you got to go
with that jet with that General Lee man
it's a beautiful car it's not racist I
knew you're gonna pick that one
Trans Am all day bro Trans Am Barnes
Ambrose
trans man I knew you were gonna say that
too
checkmate dude I knew you're gonna say
that
if you slip and fall at Dave and
Buster's picking out a [ __ ] necklace
for 2% this is Leo watching Django
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sometimes black people could hurry up a
little I sawed 12 years of slave I think
they could have done it in a step it up
to relax in that movie what else yeah 62
percent went with General Lee though ah
car beautiful car man she'll be history
Manning this guys were good Bo and Luke
Duke one of them sexual oh wow Wow
did they recreate it though did ben
stiller do that movie you know I start
seein hutch they recreated the deuce has
talked about them MTV hit us
boy she came with the naty's the daddies
first team all-natural milk jug there's
no all-natural in that girl bro except
for probably dude bad ideas this is
natural breasts I know this really yeah
you don't know dude ass Nick Lachey dude
I'm not my DNA's bro I saw him at the
airport one time in Cincinnati small
dude and I saw him too I'm not asking
him that you should ask him dude those
are all natural hitters I don't know cat
what do you eat dude they're all
naturally stalk I'm just tired of
listening to Brennan person do you know
Jessica Simpson she came a little before
you or you know Jessica Simpson yeah but
did you know her nowhere when she and
Nick Lachey were talking about chicken
of the sea
I don't know but who wouldn't think that
it says chicken on the can and you can't
tell what kind of meat it is when you
get in there really that's fair those
cans don't say it yeah is it chicken of
the sea chicken is a bird yeah sure dude
yep so it could be in anywhere it could
be in two G to me shows that you know
everyone had their favorites like
Britney and Christina Aguilera even
though she blew up now but you got yeah
I love all your favorites mine was
always Jessica's
and then before she got big I like the
brand I like the breath oh well she
doesn't like you
yeah she likes girls like women but us
women
I like JLo for a little bit I still like
JLo every bit of faux Jessica Simpson is
quickly turning into Dog the Bounty
Hunter's wife how dare you bro no she's
not she's pregnant bigger she's pregnant
there dude she's pregnant what she's
pregnant
[Music]
hunters ye bro how many nipples are on
each tip that's what I want to know she
has her little larger she has some
puppies some sweater pups oh my god did
get it done oh my gosh dude saw dog two
bounty hunter at the airport did you
talk [ __ ] to you no no he was walking by
and I wanted a government say to him but
it look do you think you're his son I
don't know I wanted to be like uh good
love Leland you know he shouldn't went
up and went good work man yeah thanks
keeping America safe yeah that would be
he was so crazy I was just sitting there
and he walked right by I'm like do you
have the glasses on yeah he's dr. Bonnie
on her yeah
yeah and all that he's not gonna he's
have short hair when he walks by he's
gonna what you think he's in a wig or
something yeah I feel like you and him
get home do the same thing go they just
have this [ __ ] here he look just like he
looks man he's beautiful guy
I can't believe again a picture with him
my god I found my dad I thought about it
man I really honestly I did regret it
early he did just lose his wife though
yeah that's what I was thinking I was
like maybe he's just going through a lot
I didn't know that's why if you would
have went up dude thanks for keeping
America safe would have made his day
yeah that's it cuz I'll see Ally I
should have handled it a little bit
differently yeah you kind of panicked
just Simpson has those sweater hitters
though I don't know how come on dude
give her the credit man
yeah hater at a certain point the tits
are attached to the brain and it just
seems like you're not getting a lot of
you know 100% brain out of that gal yeah
cuz all the fluids in her tits
she's always cutting weight I bet she
has a lot of good ideas in her tit
yeah I got some ideas well this looks
like Beth Chapman in that pit Ronald we
deny he's pregnant is she pregnant yes
she's pregnant in that Patriot crack her
hands on her belly forgot what's she
pregnant with do Beth Chapman look like
she has three kids she has another one
on the way but if you don't you yeah you
go to a younger picture and her man was
a quarterback for the Dallas Cowboys
sure Wow why I know so much I don't know
her sister sings like an angel as well
Ashlee Simpson she married a black
feller is she really yep well there's
nothing wrong with that
no I'm just giving you facts too cuz you
don't know [ __ ] he sounded like you were
driving the General Lee there for a
second but I sound like I was working
out with that Duke guy hey bro what else
we got rope chest and try I'm just
saying the guy had good for me never
said anything he spotted you well
erroneous I thought he was fair that's
fair well he was brown up next this is
from Roman from Tulsa he said in debate
club this was a little different he
didn't follow the format but I think we
can make an exception for this guy Judi
super cute uh how old is that guy
probably seven but what was the question
I have a rose with your favorite
restaurant favorite wrestlers wiv dude I
grew up were you a WWII a big bossman
baby big bossman I was my friend yeah I
was a Macho Man Randy Savage yeah
yeah doing [ __ ] dude legit I liked him
and the warrior
those are my face Alton Warriors the
best I mean my brother would act like
the bash brothers oh yeah yeah you drink
a bunch of kool-aid and it's put our
tongues out we're still doing that yeah
we'd run into each other get brain
trauma and one thing that was cool was I
remember Scott Steiner and uh the
Steiner Brothers from NWA I was never
into winema what was the other Wrestling
Federation called WCW huh brain is
slaughtered at WCW
that's always slow there's the WWE WWF
ECW a NWA it was a national Wrestling
Association we looked at it please here
because I don't know if I'm insane or if
that's a real thing that I know no
you're right NWA is a realtor but NWA I
thought was a group they were a group in
music but I know but no you're right
though to you cuz that's when that's
where I'm Cogan National Wrestling
Alliance are you right though you were
right though
cuz that's all players bang yeah that's
what a whole Cogan is Hollywood Hulk
Hogan at NWA really yeah cuz they had
the Steiner Brothers in there and those
guys were uh they were yeah both hi
Steve were always dressed like high
school wrestlers they had on the unit oh
that's cool with the things over their
ears you do cover your ears cuz I'm it's
gonna get a little graphic but dude when
I was a kid I used to jerk off to sable
from WWE you say Oh bro she's made Brock
lesner now but dude in her heyday
you put cable yeah fake milk bags I
think they're real there look nice huh
no I think they're real now remember I
was like nine so that was cool when I
was nine now I'm like oh she looks
ridiculous yes
now she looks like an [ __ ] when I was
nine
between that and Mercedes rap album oh
dude bus Ville yeah population this guy
hang back off your watch oh man dude
cmonn sir mayor busting nuts Macho Man
Randy Savage I think I liked I really
liked who was probably one of my
favorites
like you'd be like an undertaker guy no
I was back out like dog arts I like the
ultimate warrior I don't like the
Undertaker
I like the ultimate warrior I feel like
we're forgetting someone let's see Bret
the Hitman Hart Andre the Giant I like
Brutus the barber beefcake I liked him
and another the animal the Jew all guy
oh I like mankind
I don't remember mankind he put a sock
on and be like crazy it's not that's
where it got dumb I think I liked it
when they had a boss man he was a real
police officer and I like oh beware I
remember the guy with the birds oh yeah
dude how about Jake the snake
oh yeah Jake's think it's great man Jake
the snake was cool I think the snake was
great
I think but then when I was like 10 I
realized his fake I was so brokenhearted
were you yeah yeah I was bummed out you
seem like something we get brokenhearted
when they found out wrestling's fake
exactly who you are dude yep see you in
there I was sad dude god I used to bust
nuts do that though Jesus pick a path
that you fry it was a confusing time for
the kids of fluid in your body bro yeah
you're right I'm saying you ready
hydrate yeah when you write you ready
bro cat who's your favorite wrestler
dude your females have a favorite
wrestler there weren't a lot when I was
young female wrestlers I didn't really
have a favorite female wrestler I liked
Stone Cold Steve Austin Attitude Era
well I think watching the females
wrestle were my favorite parts no no I
like watching Kat let me ask you this do
you like watching women fight in the UFC
yeah that's cool that's your thing yeah
I do not like that I don't like it
either it's not a sexist thing I just
grew up different I'm not used to it so
when I see females like in violence and
proto reason it's like ah [ __ ] dude
especially if they're hot well also if
they're ugly I'm all killer
I just worry about the lady it seems to
it's just too much yeah I just saw yeah
I don't like seeing women fight each
other and let's have a sword and a
shield I don't like him see him punch
each other like even in Game of Thrones
the big the big butch one the female one
oh yeah damn no she got [ __ ] down
she's like Chris Mullins kind of that
lady when he grew his hair out no she
looks like Lottie debauch no she did not
you don't have things look what else we
must keep it cruising dude sorry no
problem my brains all over today I feel
like that's part of it no you're great
man you look terrible that I can hand
I'm just kidding you look good man you
have a glow about you bro really yeah
thanks dude I try happy to be in here
with you today I just yeah I don't know
what happened you know what this yellow
shirt triggers people man does it yeah
yeah my friends gave it to me at the
improv dude so I thought you know I'm
gonna wear it today but you have to wear
everything people give you that's how
you sound when you say stuff also it's
worth everything people what else we got
dude we got a little relationship advice
boys you know I can't tell you so many
people you saved my marriage oh my god
my life my life is so much better cuz
you and CEO [ __ ] dr. drew
it's doctor job and dr. Vaughn I'm like
all right relax first of all why does
his son laugh like an ak-47 that is very
alarming dawg sorry son but that is I
didn't realize it - I didn't either very
much a warning sound when people were
like oh we didn't see it coming we never
knew he could do it
nopales on giving all the clues dressed
like a parrot laughs like an ak-47
dressing he's totally trying to blend in
in the south or something like he's
gonna bomb a NASCAR event
let me someday learn our junior
my money that's been the mountain Dew
Code Red
what else do you get we got this is Josh
from India oh yeah probably Yosh heavy
one Brendan I'm sending you this all the
way from India and I wanted to ask you
guys a question
so brought my best friend and my Oh what
I can't and they invited me poor guy oh
you can tell he's a good dude love you
too Yosh where's thank you say this in
and not much better than the guy who
tried to kill his dog on her watch more
videos like this less about abusing
animals I'm still very insane that dog
jumped straight into a parked car
this I speak a decently high speed
although on the radar signed him after
that don't let you keep touching me
especially in a tan like tan dude you
look like somebody who definitely wants
to just say that they drive a yellow cab
bro like and you cannot you just no
other way you have to let people know
what I do bro I could see it man
I like this duty as a good heart dude
best friends can made to his
ex-girlfriend
I'll see not very good bass friend also
how long did you guys date for if you
date four years that's [ __ ] up few
months dude you were just a [ __ ] block
on the way to them getting married so
it's all good I need more details you
know I'm saying I don't need any more
details man oh yeah we've got a million
details and still have nothing going on
Brendan yeah what I must say is this
right here young fella is that I think
if you if you have any feelings for the
girl probably I think you probably just
don't go you know you don't want it to
be weird for them I think it's like it's
their day yeah you're right you're off
you're not in the picture dude you don't
go the wedding get all drunk and then
like that's sad you know yeah oh yeah
you don't want to get sad like what if
you get sad or something then people see
you being sad or you feel uncomfortable
like I would just even for yourself I
would just maybe just you know go do
something else now I know sometimes in
India the wedding is like three or four
days long so it might be that
everybody's gonna be there and there's
nowhere else even though you might not
even be able to escape the wedding some
of the weddings are so big part of it
like a Ladin or some [ __ ] you could
drive two miles yeah here's the other
thing or maybe I don't know you
good-looking dude over there in India
maybe get to some drop-dead milla keel
off where the [ __ ] that porn stars name
is get her on your arm and roll into
that wet and just drip on everybody bro
just start throwing beads like it's
Mardi Gras dude I start seeing they're
flexing on him dude but riding on a
white horse bro no rent a jeep ride ride
the white horse if you ride in on a
white horse dude people are gonna be
like oh what's up with this guy
not everybody is not little white horses
in India so you could do that
you're Arabian horses they're brown dude
Arabian think about it
also maybe write in on a Gila monster
just flip the script dude and just have
some girl some sand hitters in the mouth
enough some other lizard back sneaking
into the country brother you know that's
the last thing they need let's ask a
woman we have cat here who's a woman he
shouldn't go that's gonna bum him out
especially for three days if he goes to
every single wedding event yeah that's
you don't want to be that guy what if he
went with a what why I don't know I need
more details how long did they date for
it's just a few weeks get over dude but
if it's a while dude show up with it
what about that cat what if he showed up
with just a [ __ ] dime piece drip and
it was like who makes the girl getting
married look like [ __ ] Samuel Jackson
but then he's still gonna have
everything we'll see her and realize
always with a hot girl he's still stuck
there with his own feelings being like
oh now I'm bummed out and I gotta keep
watching this girl eat you know and
drink stuff that's a good point dude so
yeah you'd want to be there for two and
a half days was you know with a lady you
might not really be into I just wouldn't
go man
I think he probably liked the girl
enough that he's sent in this message
yeah you can tell he's kind of heard
about it say you're out of town yeah you
could say you're out of town dude you're
a closer I'd fly you here you could hang
out with a spear in India so to far
yeah that's far that's way too far dude
oh good luck though man I'd say don't go
yeah I would say it'll go man you seem
like a nice guy I'm sure you got other
opportunities for some you know for some
good women out there so you know in the
Bollywood what do you think you saw
Nissan's from from far away from here I
think he could split the difference go
to like one of the days one of the one
of the less important days bad idea I
mean at the end where everyone's tired
he's full of energy right what it's not
a [ __ ] Royal Rumble dude no you've
never been Indian wedding yes it is yes
it is dude yeah one point they throw
chalk dust at everybody it's crazy bro
at one point just put a cage around the
whole family never gets out what else we
got good luck dude up next boys a little
punk my uncle oh yeah my uncle see these
guys let me see these bro Sam
first we got uncle Leonard whoa whoa
what's wrong with is it his belly
photoshopped no that's that's his real
belly right there
apparently swallow the [ __ ] anchor
what is going on here I don't know he
looks like bad meat
speaking of WWE he looks like the
[ __ ] WS who fell in the hardest of
times this is that everyone's movie ends
in WOB yeah
just everyone looks like that dude man
holy [ __ ] he gots a goiter I think it's
called a goiter when your stomach starts
growing like another little stomach
maybe something's gonna pop out of it
yeah it looks like he's got a real piece
on him though real hoes also I think if
you gain a lot of weights do you start
gaining weight in your penis and
everything yeah that's true dude I've
been there look at the dick Peters his
hands are huge ain't no one knows how
big his dick beaters are lead his thumb
that's what nightmares are made of Jesus
first of all he has bronzer on let's get
it let's we can I mean you know him are
the same shade but whatever also what
Brazilian prison was this picture taken
in we give the
back what's going on some ports proverb
basic home no home I've ever seen oh
yeah dude he's trapped up to trap city
bro well this guy obviously used to do a
lot of weights and he still might he
might be pushing his stomach out or
something just definitely his stomach is
very he has a serious issue
I mean his belly button looks like a
little cooter you know look I don't know
it's good he's gonna die any day you
know oh yeah this guy's not doing well
yeah we're not making fun of this guy
this guy's about to die dude yeah so one
whopper away from a heart attack
probably just pass on this guy huh yeah
dude I bet this guy's veins are tasty
dude I bet he's got so much you know
salt and fat law right or whatever in
him yeah dude yeah he has traps and he
looks like these security up front of a
trap house so there's a lot going on
here yeah it seemed like it maybe one of
his intestines isn't working good oh you
got a pusher you got a squeeze one here
you got a you might have a liver disease
or something buddy he's not wearing
underwear either you know I said that's
so lazy yeah
first of all Dolson your uncle us sent
him to a doctor dog okay dude send them
to a helpline not us yeah we're not
doctors man if I looked like him yeah
I'd hire a pool cleaner to go in the
students but and firkin tighten him up
man you got to change the filter on this
dude to hidden easy something's not
going swell send him a mechanic to look
up that exhaust dude he is not doing a
roto-rooter just up that [ __ ]
something this dude needs to get drained
oh he's hiding meat bro this guy right
here he's throwing up for winter this
guy could sleep for six months dude or
to your point he might be the first
Caucasian [ __ ] terrorist bomber there
might be a bomb in this thing bro yeah I
kind of like that movie The Dark Knight
remember when the Joker put a bomb
inside that dudes stomach remember that
and I don't watch that kind of stuff but
but anyway I hope he's doing well and
good luck to you guys don't be still
alive I'm still alive don't go to the
wedding dude I say don't go to the
wedding
oh thanks we got uncle J uncle J and he
just started doing stand-up I thought
it's got to be my brother Jesus and I'll
tell you where he is honestly he's down
there in Louisiana probably apparently
he's the lifeguard of the same swamp you
are that's cool
this guy's a wife guard Brothers Doodle
watch your [ __ ] for show but this dude
don't let nothing happen to your lady
bra this dudes all about that chatter
son yeah that's a cheddar falling off
the stomach line there god damn this is
it looks like a large piece of cheese
pizza is a snowman in the winter
hey are we sure this is a human or is
that an armadillo laughs I go like this
[Laughter]
you laugh like that the shows well
that's just a song laughing no it's not
a k47 everyone be cool um first of all I
like the fact that this guy is obviously
uh it seems like he's like part of um
some type of club or something
yeah catfish killing Club he looks like
it's in fact swamp knee-deep in mud and
just goes [ __ ] Hanford's for them
catfish you ever done that no what do
they call it
doesn't call like yodeling or something
like that you know noodling they call
noodling noodling you know been noodling
I never been uh actually I've been
noodling one time of course you have yes
I watched it yeah and uh and they they
got a catfish they got a cattle
courthouse but this guy definitely look
he's smoking he's by the swamp he's got
his belly out this dude is like kind of
like the warden of the south a little
bit I think you know your mistake yeah
yeah you don't pass by the you know you
you don't call you don't collect $200 if
you passed
this guy yeah he's like the monopoly man
of the swamp you know I'm saying yeah I
like this guy I also like him he looks
like he's a good time looks a tad racist
but who's not back but not racist dude
he's just outdoors and dude you I don't
hang by a swamp and not drop in Bobby
you'll get raising the bayou and be cool
with everything what you got the man's
down there its immense yeah so yeah
you're not like oh you know secluded
where you know when will this end when
your best friend's a mosquito it's weird
but this guy's diverse he probably has
yellow fever dude the original version
not the cat version
correct correct good they have a lot of
them mean probably not bet he has a doll
look at his dog is even where's the dog
look at it down by his butt where it's a
dog right behind him right there am I
going [ __ ] crazy down am I going
crazy look at that dog down right there
dude that's his foot Theo
oh yeah it's his foot and he's wearing
socks with sandals okay now he's racing
the [ __ ] land champion yeah use a
land chip this guy's a land champ dude
it's called mudskippers reference got a
loiterer like a [ __ ] brah you
see him milling around outside of a
building dog he's doing what he does
best okay baby I like this guy man I'm a
fan too not racist he's just a guy who's
outdoors smoking a cigarette without a
shirt on but make sure you come correct
if going to the swamp especially if you
had a darker skin color yeah I will say
that well here's the thing dude if you
think he's giving everyone jambalaya got
your goddamn bro
well I think I jumble I ain't for
everybody I bet yeah you don't talk
about no I bet he's got a little bit of
jungle I I'm happy to meet a little uh a
little chocolaty vixen yeah you're right
you're probably right so but what's his
problem dude he's not sure if he wants
to go to the wedding
I feel like everybody got it buddy the
coolest wedding of all time but this guy
shouldn't go though yeah what else we
got
all right boys we gotta end it with a
little candor sting it up first this is
Jake
Rocio and Brandon this is me my boy mark
and we're here in Vegas to see Athena
bond then we're you got a kink it or
sting it for you pickle back
thanks for coming out fellas that was
the best show of the week I thought it
was fun
I liked the pickle backs man I don't
know what a pickle back is it's just
pickle juice after a shot of whiskey yep
why not why do that it's just good
because everybody cuz here's the thing
pickle juice a lot of times gets thrown
away a lot of time you see people have a
couple pickles there's a jar still with
the Jews people throw it out unused you
know well this you know pickle juice is
actually the first Gatorade is it really
has more electrolytes and Gatorade Oh a
lot of athletes drink pickle juice oh I
do know this if you're trying to get to
put on water weight then yeah you should
drink pickle juice it'll like you you
literally absorb it like 10 pounds
overnight if you just drink ton of
pickle juice straight any wrinkles aisle
deep till the show I'm one of those big
old dill pickles bro those thick ones I
don't like them slice like the whole
[ __ ] enchilada you feel me bro we
like that two-hander least have this
chick that live buzz dude named big
Martha right yeah Martha deep throat oh
dude she would always have one of them
it's a little so little sac pickles you
know yeah oh yeah we really used to come
in and see yeah like they're hot it was
yeah do not like those shoot down those
oh you should drink the gravy she always
had one yeah that's the thing but I
think people I think if you're doing a
doing a nice liquor shot there these
guys are drinking some good liquor then
I think you throw a little pickle juice
behind yeah why not what else you gonna
do yeah we're just gonna toss that one
it's fun man yeah it's a nice coca-cola
yeah yeah it kind of changes it up I
love a pickle back man so I say King
umbra King it sting these buttons Dave
this is Kyle this is Kyle boys gang gang
this is Kyle from Nova Scotia lucky Oh
Brendan you are usually present as well
Danna
mobis fallen on hard times
whoa whoa whoa what's the king of she's
accepting weights uh the strongman
competitions oh wow oh that's a lot of
weight be that's like seven that's
probably eight what 200 pounds I don't
know I just wish somebody would get on a
diet make more music that's earned bro
you did throw a little shade at you I
think I like the ones where the guys
yeah you look like a strong guy and I
think it's good if something falls on
somebody you're there you can help you
know I think being real strong is hard
to do I think that uh if you I think one
thing is that I like the contest where
the guys running on the log and he's
hitting the tree chopping the tree down
you know those ones and then they're
doing the thing where they're climbing
up the tree Ninja Warrior on ESPN no no
no no oh yeah but like in Portland yeah
[Music]
so I love those contests man but the
strong ones are crazy when you see the
guy who like throws those like those
beer keg things over the fence or
whatever
yeah like Magnus and those guys I like
the real strongman thing but unless you
want them top dogs just lifting weight
saying it strongman content yeah you
know I'm saying but it's a good sport
that it's still you know it's a good
sport that um yeah it kind of it's
almost very Greek or like you know
almost old school times where it's like
you also have no other choices you know
I'm saying like you don't become a big
fat strong man cuz you're good at
basketball
kill me well it's amazing how some of
these guys you think would be good like
offensive linemen or good defensive
linemen yeah
too athletic to be one of those guys
really yeah yeah they could never do it
oh you mean being one of them guys with
b2f yeah
wait to athlete so - honestly it's it's
weird because there's because there
yeah there you go yeah well you don't
need to do that yeah here's the thing
though with the strongman guys not this
guy well kind of
it's called fit fat right because they
lift so much weights they so much food
so they're fat but they're really strong
oh yeah it's kind of it's it's not
healthy you know I'm saying yeah you got
bratwurst four veins and [ __ ] but it's
beautiful man you know I love seeing a
big big strong guy carrying something
you know dude
and the guy the guy also they do the
things were they what else do they do
they got to pull that semi-truck and
that's a nice imagine for your semi
truck breaks down and you just got a
some skinny guy like me buy it you're
[ __ ] you got this guy with you this
dude pull it down interstate deadlift a
Prius have you seen you know get from
Game of Thrones I don't what season
you're on but you see the mountain man
he's the strongest guy in the world
yeah I heard about that shoot is he that
strong now strongest in the world she
knows he's also 400 pounds so I hope
you're [ __ ] strong you know I'm
saying good that's a good point dude I'm
174 pounds dude so I'm not that strong
but you can probably lift 170 pounds
yeah dude I dude 600 pounds bragging
that he benches 600 pounds all right
cool man
I'll king it cuz I actually dig those
strongman contests and I watch the doc -
yeah man the weights get heavy dude I
commend you for still lifting in my room
when I was young and weight wasn't where
were not that heavy now they get heavier
as I get older I get heavy yeah so if
you can be strong man keep being strong
what else did he ask about there's King
under stringer yeah I would say King at
man but I think you guys could should do
I would like to see new contest within
that contest like it's always throwing
the keg over the the whole semi yeah
let's do some real rocks yeah Kari yeah
carrying that's carrying people yeah you
start getting your fat chicks up there
and trying to [ __ ] lift them you know
the LF IX super fat chicks you know as
you think oh yeah dude viki's hmm
mountain man has a tiny like Tinkerbell
little girl but the rest of them thick
but dude it's are we into that big
amount animals probably try to come
getting your shade at night like it's
got during the day like I bet it's like
imagine two cows walk up two units take
a nap next to you dude like that big
your experience and a lot of things the
rest of us aren't experience bigger
things too you know well dude I'm sure
there's probably somebody trusted bill
you know probably you know some
Nightingale's try to build a little nest
on your shoulder like imagine dealing
with that all day while you're trying to
do the computer a grizzly bear trying to
snuggle with these guys go through again
I king it
imagine moss growing on the north side
of your [ __ ] stuff dude yeah yeah
that's why King it they're good and
they're sweaty all the time
yeah measure somebody climbs up in the
middle the night to get to get our honey
out of like a somebody's built a sack by
your ear and like you know sure things
these people go through not here that's
why Kingdom in how King it then this
says this [ __ ] this [ __ ] weird
weird we get this China alright boys is
our last one this is Alex from Tampa
what's up boo look at that white hitter
rat buzz-buzz girl I just got invited on
the Impractical Jokers cruise next year
God be such a hard pass for me really
yeah those guys are awesome
I mean their fans are awesome no they're
great stuck on a cruise with anyone yeah
be a nightmare you're talking about a
buffet of the sea you don't matter a
hotel I can't leave and I'm trapped in
the middle of a [ __ ] ocean but you're
trapped with everything you want not
really
I want to get away well you can do that
but you have to just come right back
gambling they have gambling they have
all types of soda they have free meals
all day and night entertainment what
else
pool the hard pass for me dude I don't
want to be part of it then you're on the
beach you basically live on the beach
you are your your your own Beach no but
you're stuck on this cruise ship but you
can walk around where you're not chained
to something you know I mean she can
meet other people we can put sunglasses
on
that's good point you know you can put
it you can be outside you can start
touring fish off the back are you gonna
start Torian cruises huh
what's next you and Kid Rock doing a
live tour together Kid Rock's a legend
bro yeah and he does cruises you know
does he oh yeah
Rock cruise Gronkowski did a cruise last
year really yet the Gronkowski the grant
cruise I bet there are no STDs going on
during that I mean who goes on the thing
a lot of just Pats fans probably I have
no idea
I have no I don't know anyone that goes
on cruises it's a hard pass for me dude
really that's a nightmare mine I think I
think that cruises are nice I think have
you been on one yeah I went when I was
little I hated him in did I went on this
thing called semester at sea where you
were on a cruise for a hundred days
you're on a cruise ship I always wonder
what kids went on semester at sea you
went on it yeah interesting you go to
school on there and it was fun like you
they stopped at all the ports stop it
all the other day like a lot of
different countries check it out
it was weren't rat awesome was it cool
nobody when he did that let me see I was
21
okay I thought you're a little younger
really yeah I thought you're younger I
thought you like 14 okay Wow so you just
basically went on vacation it is like
vacation but I think four or five days
cruise I like it man you get a lot of
pineapple on there they got the buffet I
don't like you know I do I would do one
section of the buffet at a time so you
don't blow it all in one meal you know I
would take it easy dude bad food and
these days the cruise is you didn't see
the one cruise that just got [ __ ]
tipped over yeah I was flying all over
the goddamn place some lady jumped off
and they never found her [ __ ] that now
somebody is always trying to kill their
wife these days yeah nobody oh she just
fell over
yeah so at night you got like 60 guys up
there trying to get their wife did you
know take a picture on the rail that's
let's recreate Titanic babe yeah all
over the front also I've seen Titanic
way too many times to jump on a giant
crew
yeah you could also just watch Titanic
and get a couple cans of dole at the
house
yes true dude so I think that's one way
to do hard sting for me um I usually
King everything three night cruise I
don't think I could do anything more
than that well that's it boys
that's it that's the episode it is
that's cool
we did it dude we did it we did it we
did it
yeah man we got to get a king in the
sing tour you know we got to talk about
it we got figured out doing yeah yeah
man thanks for her homeless update I'm
so tired for some reason I'm just
exhausted
you're hilarious man well we got through
it thank you guys
Derrick cat is on I will be at the Ice
House September 12th and I'm in Houston
and Denver and September baby Houston
Denver gang gang hometown and gang
Houston Denver that's beautiful dude no
man accusing crowds are great too some
of the best God and then Denver man
Comedy Works hometown yeah that's
awesome and good for you yeah that's
gonna be fun thanks dude I will be
watching NFL preseason football and I'll
be in Brea
I think I'm bad next week at the end of
the month or yeah our next week yeah
23rd and 24th then maybe the 25th I
might add on the show I don't know so
but I think you guys for supporting King
in the sting yes love you guys
[Music]
the king
[Music]